Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vous parle de mon Top 5 des chaines YouTube que j'aime bien.
Parce que vous le savez, le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an. Là on est à la 77 ème vidéo !
Et le jeudi, je parle de ce que je veux. Et surtout de ce que j'aime !
Je suis pleins de chaine YouTube. Je suis tous les jours pleins de chaine YouTube.
Ca me prends un temps incroyable, mais voilà, c'est ma nouvelle télévision YouTube, clairement !
En même temps, quand tu as décidé de faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an, tu es obligé d'être en immersion permanente. Enfin tu ne peux pas t'en empêcher en fait, c'est très intéressant.
Mais bon je me suis dis deux choses.
Je me suis dis, je vais faire deux vidéos d'un coup, c'est pour ça que je suis habillé comme hier et avec la même lumière qu'hier.
C'est parce que je pars en fait pour une date, donc pour être sûr moi je vais faire les deux vidéos d'un coup.
Enfin ce n'est pas que je vais le faire, mais je le fais.
Et je me suis dis surtout que j'allais vous parler des 5 chaines YouTube que j'aime beaucoup regarder et qui n'ont rien à voir les unes avec les autres.
Il y en a qui ont moins d'abonnés que moi, il y en a qui ont beaucoup plus que moi.
Voir même énormément plus.
Donc je n'ai pas pris comme critère le nombre d'abonnés. Ca n'a rien à voir avec mon choix. Il y a des gros, il y a des petits, il y a de tout.
Et c'est parti, je vous emmène avec moi.
La première chaine où je vous emmène c'est "Jeanne fait son cinéma".
Alors Jeanne est une amie, on se connaît.
Mais ce n'est pas pour ça que je vous en parle, c'est parce que vraiment ces vidéos sont très originales.
Jeanne c'est une personnalité vraiment, vraiment à part entière.
Elle est différente de tout ce que vous connaissez.
Ne cherchez pas.
On a fait une vidéo ensemble, au tout début de mon Mental Vlog, et elle a fait d'ailleurs une vidéo qui s'appelle "Jeanne s'est faite mentaliser".
Elle a trouvé une solution pour que je ne puisse plus vous mentaliser. Je ne vous spoil pas, je ne vous le dis pas.
Regardez, c'est celle-ci "Jeanne s'est faite mentaliser".
Là, elle s'est lancée dans le Vlog récemment.
Elle parle de tout en fait. C'est une personne qui écrit des scénars pour le cinéma, elle est à fond là-dedans.
Ca marche bien pour elle. Et elle tient ce Vlog-podcast... on ne sait pas trop quoi à coté.
C'est très rigolo à voir.
Une de mes préférées c'est "Jeanne fait la sirène".
Et je ne sais plus laquelle c'était aussi...
Ah oui, l'autre que j'aime c'est "Jeanne remplace le Père Noel".
Dans celle-ci, elle a des petits mots gentils pour les enfants qui m'ont fait vraiment rire. J'étais mort de rire en fait devant le téléphone.
Jeanne fait son cinéma a 209 abonnés. Mais elle devrait avoir 209 000 abonnés plutôt cette meuf ! C'est sûr !
J'ai une amie youtubeuse qui dit qu'elle va devenir une star de YouTube, mais elle a raison.
Et ça m'emmène sur la deuxième chaine que je veux vous faire découvrir.
"Le Corps, La Maison et L'Esprit", la chaine de Laetitia.
Alors Laetitia poste encore plus de vidéos que moi. C'est-à-dire que moi j'en mets une par jour, alors qu'elle peut en mettre 2 à 3 par jour.
Ca arrive. Elle peut tout faire !
Elle a énormément de catégories dans ces playlists.
Il y a "avec mes potes", "mes 5 ans de réfléxion"...
Ca c'est super. Elle a un bouquin en fait où c'est 5 ans de réflexion.
Durant 5 ans tu écris des choses, le livre te pose des questions.
Tu y réponds et une fois que tu l'as fini, tu le refais une autre année et c'est comme ça durant 5 ans.
Donc tu relis dans quels états d'esprits tu étais dans les années précédentes, et ce que tu es devenu en fait.
C'est hyper chouette.
Ça je regarde avec beaucoup de plaisir. "Mes découvertes" aussi j'aime bien.
"Mes Vlogs en voyage", en effet elle fait énormément de voyages avec Faridou.
C'est son mec ! Il est mortel ! Il est en train de prendre le pouvoir sur cette chaine. Leatitia fait très attention à Faridou.
Il y a "mes expériences bio".
Parce qu'en fait, elle est dans une consommation minimaliste, dans le zéro déchet, ce genre de choses.
Donc elle a des astuces très intéressantes. Il y a aussi les concours qu'elle fait, ces anti-swap, les mini Vlog du Bonheur, ça c'est sur sa vie et on y voit souvent Faridou, justement.
Elle poste énormément. Il y a pleins de contenu, toujours des choses à voir.
C'est "Le Corps, La Maison, L'Esprit".
En fait à la base, c'est une bloggeuse Laetitia.
Et elle a créé sa chaîne YouTube en parallèle du blog et ça se complète super bien.
Petite cerise sur le gâteau, cette meuf est juste extrêmement gentille !
Elle prend le temps de répondre à tout le monde. On s'est rencontrés, elle a d'ailleurs fait une vidéo avec moi sur sa chaine, j'en ai fait une avec elle sur ma chaine aussi.
Elle est toujours accessible, prête à discuter, à te donner des conseils, et à te donner un coup de pouce.
C'est une déclaration d'amitié Laetitia !
Publique !
Et la chaine de Vérino, c'est la troisième chaine dont je voulais vous parler.
Il n'y a pas d'ordre dans les chaines que je vous donne, je les aime autant les unes que les autres.
Vérino fait une vidéo tous les mardis, qui s'appelle "Dis donc Internet".
Et il prend un thème d'actualité, un sujet, pas forcément d'actualité au sens littéral du terme,
c'est l'actualité large.
Sa peut-être la sortie d'un film, un vrai fait de société, etc.
Et tous les mardis à 18H, il la met en ligne.
Alors il y a une particularité, c'est qu'il les tourne en public à la fin de son spectacle le samedi soir, il a un grand écran,
il y a le public derrière lui qui le voit sur l'écran, évidemment.
Et il le fait comme ça en live. Donc toutes les semaines il écrit, et après il prend le risque de les faire sur scène, une fois par semaine, tous les samedis soirs.
Donc si vous allez le voir en spectacle, vous assistez au tournage, ça c'est super, c'est mortel !
Et tous les mardis à 18H, t'as ton rendez-vous.
Vérino il a fait parti des deux personnes qui m'ont motivé, au départ, à faire des vidéos.
Ca fait à peu près un an, sauf qu'avant j'en faisait une par mois, et encore pas tous les mois...
Il fait donc parti des personnes à qui je dis merci !
Merci Vérino de m'avoir poussé à faire ça, c'était cool !
Et du coup tu as créer un monstre, puisque je fais une vidéo par jour.
Voilà, vous pouvez vous abonner à sa chaine, si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné.
Vraiment, c'est cool, c'est vriament cool.
La quatrième chaine dont je vous parle, elle n'a pas tellement besoin de moi cette chaine pour avoir des abonnés.
C'est Pierre Croce, il a 497 629 abonnés au moment où je vous parle.
497 629, c'est énorme !
Je crois qu'il y a un an et demi, Pierre avait environ 15 000 ou 20 000 abonnés sur sa chaine,
et à la fin de l'année il en avait 200 000 !
Il a dit à 300 000 abonnés qu'il fera une vidéo par jour pendant un mois,
il les a eu au mois de février,
donc durant un mois il a fait une vidéo par jour.
Et là depuis, il est passé presque à 500 000.
C'est énorme !
Ce que vit Pierre est énorme.
Mais c'est tout à fait mérité.
Il fait maintenant 5 vidéos par semaine, donc ce sont des vidéos fun, c'est toujours drôle, il n'y a pas  un thème spécifique tu vois,
il n'y a pas d'angle.
Il prend un truc qu'il le fait marrer, et il fait une vidéo là-dessus.
Il a beaucoup de formats différents.
Il fait aussi des choses avec les slides, ça c'est un truc qu'on aime bien.
Il fait ça aussi sur scène, c'est sa marque de fabrique.
Il est hyper geek.
Et il a pleins de très très bonnes idées.
Il fait aussi des vidéos participatives aussi.
Les Vlogs ! [rires]
Là, ce Vlog que vous voyez là,
il a été chez Marc Dorecel pour essayer un casque de réalité virtuel, pour regarder un film de réalité virtuelle...
Elle est à mourir de rire cette vidéo.
Je crois qu'elle est interdite aux moins de 18.
Oui ! Il a fait "On n'demande qu'à en rire" aussi.
Et il vous demande souvent aussi votre avis. Sur Facebook il demande par exemple aux internautes un sujet qu'il abordera dans une prochaine vidéo.
Et il fait la vidéo le lendemain. Il fait un gros taff là dessus.
Mais ça vaut le coup ! C'est vraiment très très bien.
Et du coup abonnez à sa chaine, si ce n'est pas encore le cas, mais...
je pense que c'est comme si je vous disais: "Vous connaissez Gad Elmaleh ?"
Et bien c'est le Gad Elmaleh d'Internet !
Voilà, clairement !
Et la cinquième et dernière chaine dont je voulais vous parler, c'est celle de Michael Hirsch.
Je ne sais même pas pourquoi je vous fait voir, puisque vous avez le retour écran d'ailleurs...
Michael Hirsch, je l'ai découvert au festival d'Avignon. Je suis allé voir son spectacle, c'était vraiment très très très très très bien.
On n'a pas gardé contact après, et un jour je suis tombé sur ses vidéos, je lui ai envoyé un message, il est venu à la maison,
on a discuté, on a fait une vidéo ensemble sur ma chaine.
En fait j'étais tombé en kiff sur ces vidéos. C'est un espèce de podcast mais qui est complètement dans l'univers de Michael.
Qui est quelqu'un qui est un amoureux de la langue en fait,
du jeu de mots, mais ce n'est pas du jeu de mots pour du jeu de mots... Il y a un vrai fond derrière.
Il y a un vrai maniement de la langue et du sens des choses.
Il fait des podcasts qui s'appellent "Lettre ou ne pas Lettre"
"Lettre ou ne pas Lettre" c'est très très agréable à regarder.
C'est très très différent de ce qu'on peut voir sur YouTube. Ca change un peu.
Et c'est ça qui me plait en fait dans YouTube, c'est qu'on peut voir des choses qui sont radicalement différentes, mais toutes aussi intéressantes les unes que les autres.
La dernière qu'il a fait c'est la lettre à Zlatan.
La lettre à Steve Jobs aussi. En fait elles sont toutes bien.
Michael, toutes tes lettres sont excellentes. De là à dire que t'es timbré.
Quand tu veux je ferais une vidéos moi, quand tu veux !
Voilà, c'était les 5 chaines dont j'avais envie de vous parler aujourd'hui.
C'est celles que je regarde le plus, quotidiennement. J'en regarde d'autres aussi mais celles-ci j'y vais quasiment tous les jours voir si il y a une nouveauté, quelque chose.
Jeanne, met des nouveautés, il n'y a pas assez de choses sur ta chaine !
Michael c'est pareil, envoie !
Envoie parce qu'on attend tes lettres, elles sont très très bien, il faut que tu en fasses beaucoup plus.
En meme temps j'ai aucun conseil à donner à personne, c'est juste que j'aime bien ce que vous faites donc plus il y en a, plus je suis heureux.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu,
et que je vous ai donné l'envie de découvrir d'autres choses. Il y a forcément une ou deux chaines que vous ne connaissiez pas dans les 5 que je vous ai cité.
Pensez à vous abonner à ma chaine, il y a le petit logo qui apparaît. Je sais qu'on vous le dit tous, mais c'est important en fait.
D'une part, c'est très très motivant pour continuer à faire les vidéos.
Et d'autre part, ça permet que nos vidéos soient plus mises en avant, et ça nous aide à nous faire connaître.
Voilà, vous savez enfin pourquoi on vous saoule avec ça.
Et demain on sera vendredi, donc je mentaliserai quelqu'un.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !